>>Josh: My name is Josh Livni. This is mapping
in 3D Tips and Tricks for the Google Earth
API and KML. I'm co-presenting with Mano Marks
and I'll just ge-, go ahead and get started
because we're a couple minutes late; talk
about a really, really easy agenda today.
I'm gonna be talking about the Earth API,
hand it over to Mano, he's gonna give us some
good, exciting news on KML, time for Q&A at
the end.
So, as with all the other sessions, we have
a Wave. I've gone ahead and put that Wave
URL at the bottom-left of most the slides,
so no worries if you didn't get it in time;
it's still down there for you to hop on and
we'll go to those questions at the end and
discuss amongst yourselves.
So, Earth API. First of all, a little bit
jargon and nomenclature. When I say that,
Earth API, what I'm referring to is the Google
Earth plugin that goes into your browser and
its associated JavaScript API. If I say the
Google Earth client or downloadable client,
I'm referring to the full-fledged application
that people might be downloading and installing
on their computers. Got that left nav bar,
turn layers on and off. But today, we'll just
be using that kind of as a reference; the
focus of, the discussions, the Earth API.
And I just wanna talk about a few things that
have happened since last year. Last year,
my colleague, Roman, gave a really exciting
talk on the Earth API lots of new features.
And since then, the team has been hard at
work at lots of stuff including, kind of first
and foremost, making sure that this plugin
is ubiquitous; that it's everywhere, and that
lots of people are using it. So, as it was
mentioned yesterday, we have over a hundred
million installs of the plugin, which is significant,
in my opinion. There's a couple reasons for
that. First of all, you guys have built great
apps, people go to your websites, they install
the plugin, and that's awesome. On our end,
we've done a couple of things. We are bundling
the API with the downloadable clients so folks
download Google Earth, they install the application
if they have a compatible operating system
and browser combination, and on that note,
we are compatible with IE7 and 8 and Chrome
and Mac and lots of browser support. Then
they'll automatically get that plugin installed
and now they don't have to see that please
install the plugin screen when they go to
your website.
In addition, you may have noticed about a
month ago or so, maps.google.com, I'm just
gonna show this really, really fast, has this
Earth view link at the top right. I apologize
for these extra buttons I have here. And it'll
pop right in to a 3D version of Earth using
the API, using the same API. This is the kind
of application that you guys can build. And
I think that says a lot of things. First of
all, it shows our commitment to this product
and we're putting it on one of our core pages:
maps.google.com. It shows the kind of stuff
that you can do with the API, integrating
into your sites, you know all the search functionality,
everything shows up just as you would expect
with a regular 2D maps application that people
are used to. And it also shows that, Hey,
we got a lot of people go to this website.
They're seeing the plugin and they're familiar
now with the controls; all of those folks,
and they already have it installed. Again,
so lots of folks have it installed.
Also, in the last year, we have a more stable
release. It was stable before, but it, it's
a bit more robust now and really it's a nice
solid plugin and fast. It's got a faster load
time and generally, we keep working on those
things, of course, all the time. But, those
are some significant changes since last year.
It's not why you're here, though. You're here
about the new features. So, that's what I'm
gonna be talking about the next little bit.
And the first big feature is a developer channel.
This is obviously aimed at you guys. And the
hope here is that we can give you an advanced
look at, at a pre-release version before we
put it out to the public so that you can get
an idea, one, of all of the up-coming features,
start coding some cool applications that take
advantage of them so when the big launch does
happen and everyone has the updated version
and your site's ready to go with cool, new
stuff. And also so you can test your sites
for backwards compatibility, make sure we
didn't accidently miss something in our testing's;
some little quirk. And also, give us feedback
what you think of what we're up to here with
our new version and, and just discuss amongst
yourselves wh-, what we've added, so that
we have a good back and forth with you guys.
To that end, you'll notice that if you go
this link, which is live right now and has
some documentation on the up-coming features
that I'll be going into, there's a link to
a forum and you can go to that forum. It's
just at Google Groups and that's for you guys
to discuss this pre-release version.
So, right now, on that channel you'll notice
the download link isn't up yet. We're hoping
to put that up really, really soon. The plugin
that I'll be demoing today is, is really the
same functionality as the one you'll be downloading
shortly. So, it's ready to go, just hasn't
quite been pushed out yet. Next, is this sandbox
that I've put together, it’s very similar
to the code playground that has a lot of our
APIs on it, but it's just customized specifically
for examples of the latest functionality in
Earth to give you some, just simple context
of how to put these features in use. And I'll
be keeping that up-to-date as we put out new
pre-releases so you've got a place to go that's
more than just a basic reference that hasn't
been fully integrated into the Docs and see
how to take advantage of the new stuff.
[pause]
So, with that in mind, the first kind of exciting
new edition is programmatic app instance time,
which is an often requested feature and just
a really cool one. It lets you do a lot of
stuff that was impossible before. So, as you
guys know, in the, the plugin you can do everything
you can with, with a full Google Earth, with
a couple of edge cases, including loadup,
time KML, get your time slider, play tours
that have time. But, once that happens, there's
really not much more you can do from there,
programmatically. So, we're now allowing access
to the time primitive using JavaScript API.
I have some simple code up here. You get the
idea. Basically, the time primitives work
on any feature, such as your placemarks, abstract
view, your cameras, your lookats, and also
this time container object: ge.getTime, you'll
notice down near the bottom. And there's a
container object for all of our time related
functions where ge is your Earth instance
that you've initialized and we'll be, we'll
be going into that in more detail.
So, in this simple case, I create a TimeStamp,
the TimeStamp is a getWhen. If it was a TimeSpan,
it would have a getBegin and a getEnd. I set
it to a string. I'll talk more about this
string format in a second. And I can set that
on a placemark or a lookat or again, the Earth
instance itself and, and set the time right
there. So, already you have a ton of functionality
that you just didn't have access to before
in terms of setting the virtual time of your
Earth instance to whenever you want so that
if you've loaded up the GPX track or something
like that, or some KML time and you want to
move to a certain location, you can do that
programmatically. So, one just short note
on the string that I mentioned, we use XML
standard for time notation and that's not
quite the same as the JavaScript date object,
and so, we have this little, quick helper
function, getSystemTime ;, which will return
a timestamp of the systems time. So, for example,
if you're building an application and people
are clicking and adding markers, you can associate
each of those with the current time. This
is a quick, little shortcut. And, we may be
adding some more useful shortcuts down the
line, depending on feedback in the forum.
So, the next piece I want to show with time,
and I'll get into a demo in one second here,
is just the fact that we can turn historical
imagery on and off. Really, really powerful
with some simple syntax. You don't need to
memorize it; I'll show it in the demo. And
we have some control over the UI, which is
an interesting concept that we didn't really
have previously in the API in terms of making
the UI come and go if you wanna make your
own controls.
So, let's take a look at some demo and actually
see, see what I'm talking about. So, first
of all, this is the, the sandbox that I've
put together. You guys can play around with
it right now. It's live. It'll be live after
this talk, so if you're watching this later
you can hop in here and check out all of this
stuff. You'll notice in this end, I'm not
gonna go through all the demos in here; they're
just to help you out using different pieces.
We don't have time to go over all the new,
all the new stuff that's added. But, in this
demo right here is all the stuff I talked
about so far. So, first of all, I add a few
placemarks and let's take a look at the function
that I used to add these placemarks. So, addPlacemark
here, I pass it at latLon, it's using the
awesome extension library that Roman and Eric
put together and this just lets us add a point
in one line. And that saves all kinds of time
and if you're not using the extension library,
you're typing more than you need to. So, keep
in mind, there's no time related stuff in
here, using extension library to, to get places
faster with the API.
But, here's, here's the basic code that we
looked at on that first code slide. We create
a timestamp, set it to a certain time, which
was the string we passed in 1988, 2012; the
various strings I made. And then just set
the TimePrimitive for that placemark and now
what we have, because we've done that, is
immediately that time slider will show up
and we have these placemarks with just a specific
loca-, timestamp. So, if I move out of the,
excuse me, range of that timestamp, it'll
go away. And all the functionality is there
that you would expect. You can play through
it and so forth and, and expand it out.
The other things that are on here, a simple
method to log the time. So, if I go ahead
and hit logTime, I should get 2012. If I set
it to the current system time, I should get
a timestamp that's slightly more convoluted.
If I go ahead and set a time span here, I
can log it and notice that it's got a start
and an end. So, that's the concept of stamps
and spans for time. Also, we can enable time
machines. This is really cool, I'm gonna go
ahead and go to, say, 1988, enable the time
machine, the historical imagery pops up and
now we can really have some power with telling
amazing stories, whether it's glaciers retreating,
or your re-enactment of something over ten
years and you wanna get this historical imagery
in place, programmatically. I think this is
just really, really cool. So, we can hop in
here, in San Francisco, and see some old imagery
before the Loma Prieta earthquake, and then
move ourselves to, say, 1995, and now we have
a bunch of parking lots here. And if we move
it to the current time, you can see them in
more vivid detail; exciting parking lots.
So, you can really see the change in time.
We have tons of imagery. If you wanna see
Haiti the day before the earthquake, the day
after, the day after that, it's really a lot
of fascinating things you can do here with
these new features. And again, if you're not
happy with this control here, we can go ahead
and just make it go away, but we still have
access to all that functionality. You can
build your own buttons and so, I think this
is extremely powerful and robust access, access
to time.
But, of course, we're not quite done with
time. The last piece is setting the rate that
the virtual internal clock of your Earth instance
moves at. And it is important to thing about
differently from just playing and pausing
cause we can set this rate to be 1, which
means for every second of real time that passes
in our lives, one second passes in this Earth
instance. Or, we can set it to 60, and every
second that passes in our real time, one minute
will pass. And so, this is, is really powerful
in terms of being able to play through things
at different rates and I'll just go through
some of these ideas here.
So, second line there, you can see we can
play a year in one second. That might be nice
if you have a ten year story to tell, you
wanna play it in ten seconds. We have the
ability to interact with UI a little bit.
So, what if, for example, someone, you've
loaded up a network link, it's got some arbitrary
KML, you don't know all the time spans; you
wanna be able to do the same thing as if that
person had hit play. We can get the calculated
rate from the UI and I'll show you an example
in a second. And you can also, if you wanna
get really fancy, get the beginning and end,
get the, basically a time span here that UI
extent so, so you know what you're dealing
with there. And then finally, just a pretty
simple API call there to set it. So, let's
take a look at that.
Demo three.
[pause]
Same simple placemarks that we had before.
I can go ahead and set the rate to 600. It
should move very, very slowly, you almost
can't even see it. I'll just start adding
some zeros to get it to speed up.
[pause]
And if you wanted to know how fast it would
play, had I hit the play button, that's, that's
fast. And we can also check what rate its
playing at at any given time, which is really
useful in case people are fiddling around
with UIs in ways you weren't expecting, or,
or maybe had done various interactions you're
weren't quite sure where they're at. So, I
think this, this basically gives us all the
things that you could wish and hope and dream
for, maybe we missed some, with time. So,
hopefully, you guys have, take good advantage
of that and build some cool stuff.
[pause]
The next topic I'm gonna get into in detail
is balloons. The main difference, really,
with balloons in the, the API versus the downloadable
client is the client ships with WebKit and
those balloons are rendered in the WebKit,
whereas the plugin renders the balloons using
the browser that people are using. So, it's
just really important when you're creating
your KML to think about cross-browser compatibility
and how that's gonna get rendered. But, the
other big difference is now we're running
in the browser with the security of the user
in the browser, and there can be all kinds
of stuff in this KML; JavaScript, other things
that could have security implications. And
so, our solution there is we just strip out
all of the stuff, which I'm gonna call active
content, for this talk. We strip out the active
content, and that means your code doesn't
work anymore; it's a little disappointing.
So, there's a few ways to work around this
and the common pattern is what we'll do is
we'll listen for a click event and if someone
clicked on a placemark and create the balloon
would pop up with say, Hey, don't pop up that
balloon actually, preventDefault is that,
the syntax there. Instead, let's get the description
of that placemark, create our own custom balloon,
a, an HTML string balloon, HTML div balloon,
and then pop that open. And because we've
done it programmatically, we can put the JavaScript
in that’s enabled and working and I'll,
I'll show you a demo in a second. And that
works great, so now we can have JavaScript
in there. But, there are some problems with
this pattern.
The first pattern is what if you have extended
data? getDescription gets the actual description.
You can get the name to sort of get what would
be by default the title of the balloon, but
more and more folks are using templates and
for other reasons using extended data and
that's not gonna work with this pattern. So,
you'll, you'll just get the description every
time instead of the actual values and the
nice rendered content that you would expect
to show up the same way, maybe in your plugin
as, as you would in Earth. And so, the solution
that we have here is a couple of new methods.
So, one is getBalloonHtml; and this will get
the content of the placemark rendered with
all the extended data in its appropriate styles
template, but that active content will still
be stripped out, which is great, because actually,
it's not a bad idea to not allow users to
run arbitrary, potentially unsafe JavaScript
and other things. Unle-, unless you're feeling
really confident you know where that KML came
from. On the other hand, you often are. It's
your KML, it's your data, and you might have
a YouTube video you wanna pop up and just
play and that would be great. And so, we have
getBalloonHtmlUnsafe;, which is a warning
to you guys, just keep in mind. That stuff's
not stripped out and so it will get rendered
with all of the active content in there, and
YouTube videos will play and the JavaScript
will make things flash and, and so forth.
That's what people do with JavaScript, I think.
So, let's look at a demo of that.
[pause]
So, balloons.
I’m gonna go ahead and just look at this
extended data example. What I'm doing is parsing
this, this KML string that I have. And what
you'll notice in this KML is I have a style
from the balloon. It's got a template in here.
You can guess it's maybe some kind of animal.
We're expecting it to say species is something
and age is something else. And when we hop
down here to the extended data of our placemark,
here's our placemark, we have some extended
data, you'll notice that we have a badger.
And the badger's age has actually got some
JavaScript. We don't want to just display
it; make people click to see the badger's
age. It should alert three for us though,
right?
So, I think I, I'm gonna reload this since
I cut and pasted there. We should have a placemark
and when we click it, we do not see the extended
data and the reason for that is down here,
it's a tricky demo, I have getDescription.
Let's go ahead and change this to getBalloonHtmlUnsafe;
and run that code.
[pause]
What we should get is a placemark with our
extended data rendered appropriately, and
if we click to see the age Appspot says three.
So, had we chose just getHtml, that alert
would, it would still render like this, it
would look like this, but you click on it
and nothing would happen. So, this is just
a really common thing folks run into. They
click on some JavaScript, they have some other
stuff, and then it just doesn't work. Why
doesn't this YouTube video show up? And so
this, this is a great solution for those kind
of more robust placemarks. It, it was pretty
much impossible before. You could get the
KML and parse it yourself, but then the styles
wouldn't apply. So, this is, this is a huge
step forward. Doesn't actually solve everything,
though. Sometimes you're popping open balloons
and nobody clicked on them, so listening for
a click event won't work. For example, there's
a tour, and you're playing through the tour,
and then you have some animation update and
the balloon pops open and there's no way to
do it. So, new balloon opening event, this,
I think's gonna be really useful for another
almost impossible situation. You can just
listen to this event. A similar pattern, except
we're listening on ge instance here. And as
soon as we hear a balloon opening, we can
go ahead and do this basically same pattern
as before, instead of listening for a placemark
click. So, it's really just a mix and match
of these which is best for your particular
use case. You don't always just want to use
this because you might have some placemarks
you don't wanna override the default thing
that happens when a balloon pops open. Maybe
you only want to do it on your particular
content. So, keep in mind, you don't just
wanna go for this, you use whatever is best
for your situation. And speaking of getting
your own content versus some arbitrary KML,
I don't have time to go into these, so I'm
just mentioning them cause I know some folks
have j-, just been begging for this because
again, it makes life so much easier. We have
a bunch of new methods. They're in the documentation.
I'm not going to go into them in detail here,
except to say if these look like things that
you've been wanting, you're really excited
right now.
[applause]
I will just wanna mention that we have some
amazing, amazing demos out there in the sandbox.
We have some partners who've built some great
stuff that you know, aren't in the sandbox
as well. Make sure you go out and check the
stuff out there. If you were around last night,
how many of you saw the VituSphere demo at
the party last night? The huge hamsterball.
And that actually can run not only their game
they were playing, their shoot 'em up, but
a shoot 'em up that Vermont, on the team who,
who not only did a lot of these cool things
that are out today, put together that uses
arbitrary controls, in this case, Virtusphere,
to have the Earth API embedded in that. So,
as you're looking around with the VR goggles
and the controller, the gun, that actually
interacts with API. So, that example, the
sandbox examples, stuff you can see in our
gallery, hopefully will give you guys some
good impetus to build some demos that we can
get you in the sandbox next year and, and
see what you do. So with that, I want to hand
it over to Mano, who's gonna talk about KML.
[applause]
>>Mano: Ok.
Look, no hands!
[laughter]
Wait, I'm not sure what that means. Ok, hi
everybody. My name is Mano Marks, thanks Josh
for the introduction and, and the great new
things. I'm real excited about what's going
on with Earth, with Earth and KML and I'm
here now to talk to you specifically about,
about KML. I've got, in particular, I've got
one technique that I’ve kind of run into
and seen if, if a couple of people develop
over the last year that I wanna share with
you. I'm gonna share that with you first because
it's old KML, and then I'm gonna share a new,
a new feature of KML cause a new, as soon
as I start trying the new feature with KML,
you're gonna wanna try it out and you're gonna
start playing with it and you're gonna ignore
the other piece. So, that's a, that's, that's
the reason for the ordering there.
[pause]
How many of you are KML developers? Nice,
nice, I like seeing that. You know there are
over half a billion KML files on the Web right
now. It's the largest; the most used geographic
data language out there. So, very, very happy
to talk to you about some things. One, one
thing I wanna talk to you about, th-, th-,
both of the things that I'm talking to you
about today are really about efficiency. So,
KML provides you, it's an XML Markup Language,
so it can be, it can be a little verbose compared
to some sort of very compact JSON strings
or something like that, that, that people
are passing around. But, but, Google Earth
has such tremendous capacity to be able to
show, you know, tens of thousands of vertices
and points on things that people tend to,
to load up their KML with lots of, lots of
stuff. Cause they really wanna show a lot.
And one of the problems that you, you run
into is, well one of the problems is bandwidth.
File sizes just get really large. And so the
first technique I wanna, I wanna talk to you
about involves using network links that incrementally
update, that get you, get you the data in
chunks so that you have a better user experience.
One, you're using less; you're using less
bandwidth, right? So, the server has to serve
less. There's less load on, on, on the server.
Two, things show up earlier for the user.
This incremen-, incrementally u-, updating
your KML shows, shows something to the user.
If you're, if you're downloading a 2MB or
5MB file all at once, then somehow the user
has to sit there and know, Oh, this isn't
broken, it's just waiting for a download.
So, I'm gonna, the technique is actually to
use update. Now, of those KML developers out
there, how many of you have used Update in
KML? Wow, ok. That, the, that is not very
many of you, but it's also, you're probably
the top 20 update users in, in the world right
now because there's, there's very few people
who actually use, use Update for, for their
KML. So, update is a mechanism that was introduced
back in, I'm not sure if it was KML 2.0, it
might have been 2.0, 2.1, but the, the objective
is to allow for changes to KML that's already
been downloaded using a network link. So,
lemme, let me do a quick overview of what
the, what the technique looks like. Now, one
reason that update isn't used very often is
this is actually fairly complex. One of the
themes that you heard from Josh, when he was
talking about balloons is, is security. And
one of the things that we, we wanted to do
was to be very careful about allowing different
sites to, or rather, not allowing different
sites to update and change KML that's already
loaded by somebody else. So, what, we had,
we had to put in a mechanism that made that
difficult to do. So, the first thing you do
to, to accomplish this, is you, you load a
network link. Alright, so the network link
goes off to a server and downloads, downloads
some KML. The second thing you do is load
a second network link. This is usually the
point where people get a little stuck because
that's, that requires that the developer,
they think, that requires that the user then
download yet another network link. The idea
is the, the first network link downloads some
KML and then the second network link goes
off and downloads a network link control,
which is what you see on the right. Well,
the technique that you'd do to get around
the, the user actually having to download
a second one, is you put the second network
link in the first file that's downloaded.
So, the first network link downloads, downloads
a file that has within it the network link
to the network link control. It goes off,
gets the network link control, and in that
network link control, what it does, is it
has an update element with a create element
that creates a whole bunch of placemarks,
or whatever it is that you're, you're downloading.
The other thing it does is it iterates a cookie.
So, this cookie then gets attached to this
network link control. It's the only place
in Google Earth that you have a cookie that
is persistent.
[audience member coughs]
So, this cookie gets attached to this net-,
network link and the network link control
basically successively iterates the cookie.
So, you, this cookie doesn't actually have
to be, it doesn't have to be something that
the, that personally identifies the user.
You could use it that way. It's a lot more
complicated and if you wanna figure out how
to do it, I'm sure you can, it's just lots
of additional steps. But basically, it's,
it's a counter that tells how many times you've
hit the server and then the server just makes
a decision then. Ok, I'm gonna, I'm going
to go back and, and get the second or the
third or the fourth either KML file, or batch
of KML; however you wanna, you want to generate
it. So, that's, that's what this, this diagram
is showing and let me show you what this actually
ends up looking like.
[pause]
Both Josh and I basically have recently shifted
to using, using Macs, so we're a little slow
on the Mac. That's what, that's what you're
seeing here. Ok, so, we've got a little server
running a local host here. And you see here,
it downloads, I, I've got it set to update
every four, four seconds. Basically what I
did is I just wanted to up-, do something
fairly simple to illustrate the, the concept.
But the first, the first batch of data is
a, it's a KML that puts a placemark every
point of longitude at one latitude, and just
does that from zero to 180 longitude. So,
so you see there. And then each successive,
every four seconds when it goes and hits the
server again, it loads the next one, which
just does the same thing but shifts it up
by one, by one point of latitude. So, you
can see here, the user, and you can speed
this up, you don't have to do this in one
second. You can do this in, or four seconds,
you can do this in one second. You could also
load larger amounts than I'm showing you here.
But the idea here is, is basically just to
show you this, this sort of gradual increase
of data in the, in the client. So, to the
user, it, it, it appears to happen very fast,
but gradually more data gets in there so the,
the user can then start, the user then knows
that something's going on and can start interacting
with it while the network link is still going.
[pause]
And, there, ok. So, that's the tip. So, now
we're gonna get back to time.
[pause]
How many of you have tried to animate a model
in KML before? Ok. How, or point, you could
use a geometry, use time, time animation?
Ok. So, a few, a few years ago when we introduced
time to KML, back, back when we owned KML,
before we gave it away to the Open Geo-spatial
Consortium, we, we did it in order to add
a fourth dimension to data. And the idea was
that people could display time-related things.
A point changes, moves, say you have a path
that you're describing. You could, you could
show it only during the time periods in which
it's, which it was, it was active. But people
immediately latched on to it as a way to do
model animation. So, they put in time whether
or not it was related to actual time. They
put in time that, you know, you could put
in time codes of, you know, one-two-three-four-five.
Basically, they wanted to use it for, for
time animation. They wanted to use it for
large data sets. And the problem with time
is that for every placemark, for every geometry,
for everything you did, for every piece of
time, you had to recreate that. You had to
create a whole new one with a new timestamp
or a new time spent. And lemme show you what,
what that might actually look like. So, Frank
Taylor was kind enough to give me a GPS, a
GPX track that he, of his trip. So, Frank
Taylor runs the Google Earth blog and he's
now taking a trip around the world; he's sailing
in a boat. It's very cool. And I converted
that GPX track to a KMZ using this, using
this method. And you'll see there that there's
a line and it's got a, it's got a path and,
and, and this is what it, it will physically
look like, like if I play it, lemme zoom out
a little bit. Press play. Gonna set the rate
down to one hundred so that you can actually
see what's, what's going on.
>>Josh: Set rate to 100 and then hit tab
>>Mano: I did hit tab
>>Josh: I think you hit the play button
>>Mano: Ah
>>Josh: [inaudible] put it back to the beginning.
[pause] Don’t, don’t use the UI to play,
just change it to 12,000 and hit tab
[audience member coughs]
[long pause]
>>Mano: Ok. So, you'll see, first of all,
you may notice that it's really slowing down
my interface to move, to move through it as
it's, as these, as this time is playing. Lemme,
lemme tell you what this; show you what the
code actually looks like. This is what the,
the KML for this actually looks like. Placemark
with a timestamp, you might put in multi-geometry
or a single geometry. You could get away with
putting the timestamp maybe on a folder that's
got a whole set of geometries, but regardless,
you're, you're creating many, many placemarks
and not only that, you're, for something like
this, you're gonna have to create many, many
styles because the point, at the end of this,
if I can find it here, is, is actually an
arrow. And that arrow changes directions.
And so every placemark that changes the direction
of the line has to then have a separate style
with a separately configured direction on
it. And, and it gets to be kind of a mess.
You see how this is actually look-, moving,
I don't know if you can tell, but it's moving
very slowly as I, as I pan through it. That's
because this file, it has 24 thousand points
along the GPX track. And it, and it created
a file that was 21MB in size. So, you think
there, there must be a solution to that and
people often said to us, Well, why don't you,
instead of creating a new point for every
point in time, you allow us to move the point?
So we did. So, we're gonna announce today
a new extension to, to KML, which is Track.
Now, Track is a way of, of, of moving a single
point through space. Now, that point can actually
be a point or it could be a model. So, you
can use this for both animating a, a specific
point, or you can use it for animating a 3D
model along, along a particular route. Now,
there are the basic, Track is a geometry,
so it lives inside of a placemark. And one
of the reasons this is, this is important
is that, you'll notice before, we were creating
a placemark for every single, for every single
new timestamp, for, to, you know, we'd have
to repeat that. Well, placemark is one within
your own KML code, its heavyweight. It takes,
you know, there's a lot of code to, to create
a placemark. The, two, it's actually fairly
heavyweight within, within Google Earth itself.
It, you know, there's a lot that's associated
with the object code for that. So, Track is
a, is a geometry, which is a much slimmer,
much smaller thing within our own application.
And for your KML, it's going to be a lot,
a lot slimmer as well. So this, this uses
a technique of parallel arrays. So, you see
here, I just took a, a very small sample,
obviously, of the 24 thousand points along
the way. There are three when elements and
there are three gx coord. The gx prefix identifying
it as being in our extension namespace. These
are parallel arrays. So, the first when element
corresponds to the first coord element, the
second to the second, the third to the third.
Still, still a lot of writing for the individual,
the individual points, but the file, the same
file that produced the 21MB file, when using
a traditional methods, one, I'm sorry, 2MB,
2.2MB, and dropped that down to a KMZ, so,
compressed version; 640MB, including the 3D
model inside of it. I'm sorry, kilobytes.
[Mano laughs]
For you on YouTube, let me repeat that: 640KB,
including the model and the textures that
were used on the model. So, let me show you
what that looks like.
[pause]
I'm gonna zoom in. What I did, was I took
a model that, that Frank had done for his,
for his boat. And I'm getting a little slowdown
on my--
>>Josh: Change the rating to about 1200
>>Mano: Ok.
[pause]
So, you see here that the model is moving
along there and it's moving along there and
it's got a point, a point associated with
it as well.
And it continues to move in, and I'm gonna
zoom in along that track. This is actually
made up of, of four different tracks, but
the effect is essentially the same. I didn't
do any, any optimization on this. I didn't,
you know, reduce the file size by getting
rid of all the spaces or anything like that.
Take ano-, another look at, you see how the
model is actually changing its orientation.
I did nothing to accomplish that. I did not
add in a single line of KML to do that. I
could have, actually in Track we also support
gx angles, which is a separate parallel array
that gives you the different angles that,
that the model would be facing at. But, no-,
nothing to accomplish that. It automatically
detects where, you know, where the next point
is and reorients the model, accordingly. So,
that's a, that's a pretty tremendous, a pretty
tremendous benefit.
[pause]
So, I'm, I'm really excited to see this as,
as I said. Both these, both these techniques
that I've demonstrated today are gonna really
help you in creating much more efficient KML
and also creating really interesting animations
using, using Track. And the one last, the
one last point that I wanna make at this point
is that we're, in the, in the conversion from
a GPX, we're also gonna be putting in a mechanism
for you to retain the metadata that might
be coming along with your, with that, with
that track. So, in that G, in some GPX files,
you have things like heart rates, if it's
a heart rate monitor. Or, you might have on
your mobile device things like the position
of the phone itself, what, you know, what
your orientation is, that sort of thing which
could then be used, very easily, within our,
within Track to reposition a model of yourself
or something like that. Ok, so that concludes
sort of the technical portion of the presentation.
I wanna give a little shout-out to, for Google
Developer Qualification. Those of you who
have been to other Geo Talks know that we
started Google Developer Qualification program,
which includes all of the, the APIs you see
there, and we're announcing, right now, the
inclusion of KML. So, those of you who want
to become qualified developers, which would,
basically means that we recognize that you
pass a test and you contribute to community,
and you keep your skills up, then you get
listed in the Qualified Developer Program
and that's, that gives you, gives other people
access to you. I mean, basically what happened
was for years people have been saying to us,
Hey, do you know a great KML developer? And
we'd just all be like, well, off the top of
my head, Josh Livni or, you know, something.
And then we'd hire them and then we'd have
one less person we could recommend you to
get outside. So, you could be those people
and now we can, we can point them to a site
so we don't all have these separate spreadsheets
and, and everything. In, and it's a more objective
evaluation. So, this is a, this is a great
program so please get involved.
Now, Josh, you wanna come up on stage and
we'll go ahead and--
>>Josh: Yeah, let's do that
>>Mano: Do you have the Wave already up?
>>Josh: I got it here.
>>Mano: You got it there? Ok.
>>Josh: Let's ah, click it in
>>Mano: Oh. You probably need this, too.
>>Josh: Yeah, probably. We'll prop this up
here. While we're getting this up, do you
guys wanna head up to the mic with any questions
you have?
[pause]
>>audience1: Yeah, hi. With the Track that
you just showed, it's not focusing on, on
the point. It's not following it, is there,
would it do it automatically, or would you
have to add like a code for focus or follow
or something like this? And does Track work
in Google Earth, KML? --
>>Mano: So, that's a, that's a good point.
So, everything that you've seen right now
will not work in the current, except for the
update tip that I gave you, will not work
in the current release version of either Earth
or the plugin. They, it will work in the developer
channel release and both of, in; they're targeted
to work in both the release versions of Earth
and the plugin when they're finalized. It,
feedback like that, that's great feedback,
we haven't finalized how the user interface
is gonna work, so contribute that to the developer
channel and we really, we'll be really interested
to hear about that.
>>audience2: So, two quick questions. You
may have already said it, but what was the,
what's the reduction in memory, or, or, how
do you quantify this performance increase
when you're doing Track versus trying to use
points to do animation?
>>Mano: How do we quantify it? I, I did the
conversion and tested it.
>>audience2: I mean, what was it?
>>Mano: So, is, same Track produced a 2MB
track file and a 21MB traditional placemark
animation file.
>>audience2: Gotcha.
>>Mano: And the larger the file, and the more
points, the more likely it is that that's
gonna be a larger and larger file because
the more twists and turns you have, the more
styles that you need, etc. So, that's gonna--
>>audience2: The second question is we're
actually using Google Earth on a, on a production
implementation now and, and we have two viewport
windows so we show one sort of 3D view and
another top-down view. We have a lot of problems
with, with, in the launching of those two
Google Earth instances. It actually starts
up two processes on the machine. Is there
sort of a best practice to stagger the launch,
or is that a known bug, or, or are you aware
of that kind of an issue?
>>Mano: Josh, do you wanna take it?
>>Josh: Is this regarding the API and loading
up two in the browser at the same time?
>>audience2: Correct, yes.
>>Josh: Yeah, I don't think we have a best
practice, but I have found that if you maybe
just do a set timeout of like, 200 milliseconds
or something like that, the, the way that
the API uses memory is we don't share the
cached, the cache, the memory cache there,
and so they kind of initialize a chunk of
space for each and, yeah. I mean it's an interesting
question, I haven't really tested, tested
that, but I have found that if, if you just
set like, a small set timeout, a quarter of
a second or something, that can stop some
of the jerkiness that might pop up.
>>audience2: Ok, thank you.
>>Mano: Ok, so lemme go to the Wave for some
questions. The most popular question here
is, How do you keep the plugin from leaking
too much memory when setting--
[phone ringing]
custom HTML balloons ? When you create an
event listener it is quite difficult to remove
the event listener and it sits in memory of
the plugin.
>>Josh: Good question, so it seems like two
separate questions. You don't need to set
an event listener when you create the, a custom
HTML balloon. You can create those and when
you close down those should be, at least to
memory, as far as I know, I, I've definitely
set up a couple things which had many thousands
of maybe custom balloons open and close and
I, I didn't notice the increase in memory,
but I haven't really looked at that. As for
the event listener, yeah, I don't think we
have a good way to remove event listeners
so that's a really great request for the public
issue tracker, bring it up in the forum and
when we get that kind of feedback. Oh, we
do? We have a remove event listener? I hear.
I take it back. We do have one, and I'm unfamiliar
with it. That's probably in the reference,
the API reference. So, I'm glad that the experts,
and that's a good point. The experts in the
team right here correct me. Yeah, so you should
use the remove event listener and, and get
that out of your memory there.
[phone ringing]
>>Mano: Ok, so, then the next question is,
Is this available on mobile devices and browsers?
The answer is at this point not, not yet.
It's something that we're evaluating. It's,
you know, every, every additional implementation
makes it a, you know, more engineering work
on our part. So we're, we are looking at that
and we're aware that there's actually quite
a bit of interest in doing that.
So, then the next question is, Is there a
Linux version of the plugin?
>>Josh: There's not a Linux version of the
plugin as, as the popular discussion on the
IssueTracker right now is well aware. But,
I am happy to say that we have the intention
of, of building ah, some Linux compatibility
in the future. We just don't have a timeline
to announce right now on that. But we definitely
pay attention to your guy's feedback and we
know that's a popular request.
[pause]
Ah, some questions up here.
>>audience3: Yeah, if I construct multiple
parallel arrays would I be able to dev multiple
tracks running at the same time?
>>Mano: You mean, within the, yeah so we actually,
there's one element I didn't show which is
called a MultiTrack so you can, you can create
a multitrack, which is a container for tracks.
And so you can certainly have multiple ones.
You can also have different placemarks, which
have different tracks in them; however you
want to separate that out. And they can have
timelines that overlap and they will play
successfully. That was actually one of the
design goals was to allow you to have that
kind of implementation where multiple tracks
were playing at the same time. Imagine a boat
race instead of a single boat, for instance.
>>audience3: Thank you.
>>Mano: Sure. Yes.
>>audience4: Have you thought about an HTML5
WebGL version of the plugin?
>>Mano: We're always looking at, at new technologies
that when we set out to do the, the plugin
originally, we didn't, HTML5 was nowhere near
what we needed and so. So, we're always evaluating
where we're gonna go with that in the future.
The truth was we were able to repurpose a
lot of the Google Earth code directly, so,
yeah. I mean it's something that we're looking
at and the Product Manager for Google Earth
is sitting in the audience right here, Peter
Birch, he's very tall. So, you can, you can
single him out and ask him about that.
>>audience4: Ok. Thank you.
>>audience5: [middle eastern accent] Hi. Is
there any way to unload the Google Earth plugin
like you have GUnload for Google Maps API?
>>Josh: An un-, an unload event so that when
someone, say, moves to another page it, it
releases its whole memory stack?
>>audience5: Right. Because sometimes, when
I close the browser, the GEPlugin is still,
you know, running in the background, so.
>>Josh: So, not that I'm aware of. I may get
corrected again in a moment, I do not believe
that we have an unload. Yeah, if, if you do
close that, that window it will clean itself
up, or if the instance goes away I think it
sounds like it might hang around for 5 seconds
or something? 30 seconds, so yeah, we have
that.
>>[answer from audience] 30.
>>audience5: A few times I have, like dozens
of GEPlugin instances in my Task Manager,
so, that's why, you know, I why I was looking
for…
>>Mano: I'm sorry, I can't understand.
>>Josh: Yeah, I missed that. You said you
have a lot of different Earth plugin instances?
>>audience5: Yeah, like I, I keep, you know,
running the Google Earth instance in different,
I mean, in the browser and then I close them
and then suddenly it doesn't load--
>>Josh: It doesn't free up the memory right
away. Yeah, it sounds like there's about a
30 second delay. If you have lots of different
instances it's good to note, I, I believe
the way that the memory works is they get
successively less memory for each one, so
just keep that in mind if you're gonna be
loading up ten, not to expect your tenth one
to have the same cache available to it as
the first one. But yeah, it sounds like there's
a little bit of a delay there, to, to keep
in mind.
>>Mano: Actually, I believe, don't they share
this, the caches? No? No, sorry.
>>googleperson: It’s actually that they
get the same size
>>Josh: They get the same size?
>>googleperson: They get the same memory but
with smaller disk cache
>>Josh: Oh, smaller disk cache for tiles and
so forth, that's a good point. Yeah. Nonetheless,
I mean, it is a good point, we don't have
an API method to say unload. And, and so it
just kind of automates itself after--
>>googleperson: That sounds like [inaudible]
>>audience5: Sure. Thanks.
>>Mano: Yes?
>>audience6: Will the JavaScript API get an
update with tracks in it on the next plugin
release, or is that just a KML feature?
>>Mano: So, we, we don't have a timeline for
when it will get into the, into the API itself.
We do intend to allow you to do anything that
you can do in KML, in the, in the API as well.
So, I, I can't tell you when it-, it'll happen,
but that's, that's definitely on the road.
>>audience6: [Indian accent] There seems to
be some interest of using Street Maps on Google
Earth plugin. Have you all thought about providing
the kind of data instead of the terrain?
>>Mano: Street Maps though like using our
map tiles from maps.google.com?
>>audience6: Yes.
>>Mano: Yeah, this, this is something that
periodically people do request of us. There
are some, there's not a lot of actual technical
problems from our end, although it is a, they
are different sources of, of data. There are
some licensing issues that make it less than,
less than ideal for us to go and do it, and
it hasn't been requested enough that we, we
have felt compelled to move towards it. It's
actually, so if you put it into the Issue
Tracker and lots of people star it, then it
is something we might take a little bit more
interest in. We do, of course, have a Roads
layer in the, in the API, so you can see the
actual roads overlaid on top of the satellite
imagery.
>>audience7: This is more of a comment than
it is a question. I work for a public agency
and we're behind three layers of firewalls.
I'm having a very difficult time rolling out
Google Earth as the standard product. The
Google Updater interferes, all the security
things get thrown, so I went with the Google
Earth API for the browser and then I found
I can't render the KML because it's behind
the firewall. So I have to obfusticate the
KML, make like measle dot kind of stuff and
stuff that out on the Internet so that I can
view it through the Google Earth API browser
based ways because I can't view KML on a intranet
site
>>Josh: So--
>>audience7: so I'm like, trapped, in-between
kind of a purgatory
>>Josh: So a work around for that, which we
showed here, is you do need to have a Web-,
a Web server serving up your KML content.
You can't load it off a local file, your local
disk, again, for those security reasons we
mentioned. But, on the other hand…
>>audience7: If I have regular Google Earth
application I can, but I can't have my end
users install it for security issues--
>>Josh: Yeah, so we don't want, for example,
if you load up a network link, and it says,
Hey, let's go ahead and open up everything
in c temp whatever, on some user's machines.
So we don't allow the browser to access those
files, but a workaround that we showed here
is running just a really simple local host
server, you know a trivial one. That was just
Pythons HTTP simple server up at, but there's
many simple servers you could maybe run internally
just to serve up KMLs and that would solve
the problem of internal serving of those.
>>audience8: Hi. I was wondering if it's possible
to update the map with something like a live
stream of a KML input?
>>Josh: Sure.
>>Mano: Sure. Which, which map are you, or
you just wanna put KML on your, are you talking
about rbase map, or are you talking about
being able to display KML on your site?
>>audience8: I'm talking about KML stream
that is continuously updating.
>>Mano: Right. So, if you use a network link,
the network link can be constantly pinging
your server. You could set it to times as
short as once a second. In fact, the update
mechanism that I showed you is precisely that.
I, it doesn't, we ran everything off a local
host here just because, you know, conferences
you have to be really worried about Internet
access, but in general you would have your
own server that serves it out.
>>audience9: I just have a quick question.
Are you guys gonna do any other projections
for the globe?
>>Josh: I'm sorry, what was the question?
>>audience9: Projections? Like, map projections,
like at the polar regions, it all gets distorted
and like, equal area, like equidistant projection?
There's a whole bunch of different map projections.
>>Josh: Yeah, so you were hoping we would
support arbitrary projections on the globes?
>>audience9: Correct.
>>Mano: Well, I, I mean, the, the globe is
a globe. I mean, it's a little different--
>>Josh: There is a good point in that the
Plate carrée projection that sort of defaults,
what some people call WSG 84 for projection
although it’s a Datum is, it has some warping
near the poles and it is possible if you were,
for example, a Google Earth Enterprise customer,
to build your own globe and then you could
set the, it would still have to be a similar
projection, but not have the globe distorted,
have somewhere else distorted. But, somewhere's,
somewhere its gonna bound off into infinity
on the globe. I don't know if that answers
your question.
>>Peter: Yeah, just, I'm Peter, the Product
Manager, just a couple more details on that.
I mean, part of the issue too is that all
the need of infrastructure is in Plate carrée
projection, so it's not something that is
easy for us to change. We, I mean, obviously
the pole issue is an ongoing issue with that
projection and we've looked at some different
solutions. Hopefully, at some point, we'll
be able to, to do something that will address
the pole issue. But, we don't have any plans
for kind of an arbitrary projection because
a lot of our data is natively stored in [inaudible].
[audience member coughs]
>>Mano: So, the last question that's on Moderator
here is, Is there an offline version of the
GE plugin available to download? And the answer
is no at this point.
>>Josh: Yeah, I mean it does work offline.
You don't have to have it in online and again,
if you're an Enterprise customer with your
own globe then you don't have to connect to
our servers. But, it's not gonna do much offline
if, if it can't get any of our data unless,
unless you're only loading your own data set.
>>Mano: Well, and also, it needs to be online
for the, when you start, when you start the
plugin.
>>Josh: Yeah, the initial JavaScript, I think,
you could, I'm not sure, is it against the
terms of service to grab the JS loader and
put it locally? Probably.
>>Mano: Probably.
>>Josh: Probably, yeah.
>>googleguy: In IE the browser will cache
it for a second.
>>Josh: That's true.
>>Mano: Yeah.
>>Josh: I'm not sure what the terms of service
say--
>>Mano: But, but I, I think this is probably
more, more, they're probably more interested
in what's, is the person who asked this in
the audience? I'm gonna guess that you're
more interested in having an offline version
for installation purposes, right? Is that
right?
>>audience10: [Indian Accent] Yeah, for the
installation. For most of the times, you know,
because the end user are behind the firewall
and cannot connect to, they cannot go to Google
Earth and when they--
>>Mano: Yeah.
>>audience10: come and download the software.
>>Josh: Yes. An offline installer. We don't
offer a link to a here's the latest offline
installer for you guys to put throughout your
organization. But that is, that is a future
request that we have in mind.
>>Mano: It's something that's frequently requested
and we're definitely looking at that to allow
for enterprise installations.
>>audience11: I was out on the forums griping
about this very issue and somehow or another,
I found my way to the exe for Google Earth
5.1, I forget what build, what version, and
I downloaded that and I put it out on my local
shared drives, that like five thousand people
have access to and I told them to go get that.
>>Josh: I, I mean, that is a good point which
I mentioned earlier, is we bundle the plugin
and the API with a downloadable client, so
if, if you have that installer locally, it
would have installed the plugin. We don't
have a separate plugin-only option.
>>audience10: [Indian accent] Is there any
way we get to choose which version to download
or which version to install, because right
now updates automatically when there are any
updates.
>>Josh: So, that's kind of one of the, the
big advantages of the Developer Channel, is
it no longer has to come as a big surprise,
Wow. Everything got updated and now I'm at
a new version. By joining the Developer Channel,
you'll get access to that kind of prerelease,
as long as, as well as, you know our release
nodes that we'll post when we update that
to the forum, and you'll know it's coming
in general a couple weeks ahead of time and
before the public launch. So, that hopefully
will help solve some of that.
>>audience10: Thanks.
>>Mano: Peter has some qualifications on that
>>Peter: Jumping in a couple questions. So,
one issue is we don't allow arbitrary download
of any version and part of that is because
it's sort of like if you can't go to a certain
version of website, its, you know, every time
you go to the website you get all new JavaScript,
all new code. You know, this is a combination
of a JavaScript API and a plugin necessary
for it to work, and they work in harmony,
so it's not always an option for us to say,
Oh, yeah, I get five versions back. and run
it because it probably won't work anymore.
There will be other compatibility issues.
So, for enterprise customers we do bundle
a sort of offline package so they can be run
and supported for a certain window of time,
but in terms of open consumer, where people
are pulling out and going to a bunch of new
websites, you want to be able to have a very
robust, well-tested single version that's
updated that everybody is using so you don't
have to worry about, you know, five or whatever
different versions out there.
>>Josh: So, that's, I think we're out of time
there.
>>Mano: Yeah, unfortunately.
>>Josh: But, we'll be around up here to answer
questions or maybe outside, actually to answer
questions--
>>Mano: And also, I believe there are Geo
APIs, office hours going on upstairs and probably
one of us will be up there for that at one
point. So thank you very much for coming.
>>Josh: Thanks, guys.
[applause]